[Música]
vamos ahora las noticias de la salud con
más Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela y bienvenida de nuevo
directo a América vamos a empezar con
buenas noticias los hospitales y los
sistemas sanitarios empiezan a
recuperarse después de la pandemia
sabemos todos Ángela que el covid dejó
unas interrupciones difíciles de
calcular en todos los sistemas de salud
en los hospitales y especialmente en
esos servicios que no estaban destinados
a combatir particularmente la emergencia
sanitaria pero parece que tres años
después de estar remitiendo están
remitiendo estos efectos no hay un
informe de la OMS que evalúa este
impacto es el cuarto publicado desde
2020 que lo hacen periódicamente y en
términos generales vemos que se han
reducido estas interrupciones hablamos
de que si en el tercer trimestre de 2020
los países reportaban interrupciones del
56% es decir prácticamente más de la
mitad de sus servicios sanitarios a
finales de 2022 e inicios de 2023 esta
cifra había disminuido al 23% Lo mismo
sucede en casos más concretos por
ejemplo en primaria a finales de 2021
sabíamos que había una interrupción del
53% también se redujo al 23 por 23%
perdón a finales de 2023 y en servicios
de emergencias en un año también pasó
del 35 al 16% es decir donde tenemos
buenas noticias para decir que nos
estamos empezando a recuperar después de
tantos años de interrupciones y en más
buenas noticias también destacadas por
el informe varios países reportaron que
sus sistemas de salud habían podido
integrar todos esos servicios todas esas
estrategias que se diseñaron para
combatir el covid 19 a su rutina diaria
de atención y especialmente los países
que han tenido que combatir otras crisis
sanitarias por ejemplo la del empox o
viruela del mono también pudieron pues
poder redirigir todo eso que habían
aprendido durante la pandemia a combatir
estas nuevas crisis entonces bueno
tenemos un balance bastante positivo y
ese es el llamado sin embargo hay una
cara negativa en este informe mar No
todo está solucionado no muchos vivimos
intentando dejar atrás los efectos del
covid 19 nuestras vidas diarias pero en
los hospitales no se puede hacer eso Y
todavía se siente el informe por ejemplo
menciona que hay una falta de
trabajadores de la salud que está
provocando que la atención sanitaria
también se retrase o no sea tan buena
sabemos que fue una época muy dura para
muchos trabajadores de la salud en
condiciones además especialmente
difíciles y no tan buenas en términos de
descansos o salariales en muchos países
del mundo y de hecho también como hemos
contado otras veces eso ha provocado que
en muchos países por ejemplo que están
en vías de desarrollo sus trabajadores
sanitarios migren a otros países para
poder conseguir mejores trabajos o
mejores condiciones y dejen esos
problemas o esa desatención en sus
países de origen también se menciona que
hay una Falta de confianza en los
servicios de salud que se arrastra de
ese momento de pandemia las personas no
van a buscar atención sanitaria de la
misma forma en que lo hacían antes del
2020 eso puede ser porque no confían en
que puedan ser bien atendidos después
del caos que hubo no en el 2020-2021 que
no se conseguía atender otras
enfermedades que no fueran el covid 19 o
también porque se perdió la costumbre o
la rutina Entonces eso son cosas que
todavía se tienen que mejorar Pero
además hay un tema clave también que
menciona el informe que es el tema de
los retrasos en la atención los tiempos
de espera la mayoría de los países que
respondieron la encuesta dicen que han
aumentado estos retrasos en vez de
disminuir principalmente en el monitoreo
o el tratamiento de enfermedades no
transmisibles también en los servicios
de rehabilitación en las citas con los
especialistas en los tratamientos o
diagnósticos de enfermedades tan
importantes como el cáncer y también en
esas cirugías opcionales que se llaman
opcionales pero no son opcionales en
realidad es decir Simplemente no son
inmediatas no son urgentes pero pueden
tener efectos a largo plazo en la salud
también pues usted lo explicaba muy bien
Esto es un proceso no ha terminado y hay
que ver a partir de aquí que mejoras se
pueden lograr mar seguimos hablando de
salud pero ya en otro tema Hoy se
celebra el Día Mundial contra el asma si
hoy 2 de mayo se conmemora esta
enfermedad estos días sirven mucho para
recordar enfermedades que a veces
desapercibidas y el asma es un gran
ejemplo de ello porque se considera una
enfermedad menor pero sus impactos
pueden tener muchas ramificaciones según
cifras generales de la Organización
Mundial de la OMS que son de fecha de
2019 en el mundo hay 262 millones de
casos de asma muchísimas personas sufren
esta enfermedad y provoca alrededor de
455.000 muertes anuales el asmas la
inflamación de los vasos pulmonares y al
inflamarse hace que no haya tanto
espacio para que el aire pase Y eso pues
provoca que haya una dificultad para
respirar o que haya problemas de oxígeno
en Casos graves o que no se pueda
entregar puede llegar a provocar la
muerte y además es la enfermedad Crónica
más común en la infancia y la foto del
Salbutamol que es el mejor amigo de las
personas asmáticas y muy importante para
poder que para poder hacer que la gente
viva con normalidad con esta enfermedad
no Pero por supuesto que provoca el asma
marmar pues Angela la verdad es que
todavía no se sabe hay una incógnita
alrededor del origen de esta enfermedad
se sabe que hay varios factores factores
genéticos de un lado pero también
ambientales como la polución el tabaco
las alergias también sabemos que van de
la mano y es importante destacar algo
que aquí vemos en un comunicado en un
informe de la Universidad de California
que habla de California pero se puede
aplicar a todo el mundo que dice que las
personas con bajos ingresos experimentan
los síntomas con más frecuencia del asma
que van a urgencias y a los hospitales
más a menudo y que pierden más días de
trabajo y también más días de escuela en
el caso de los niños y las niñas a raíz
de esta enfermedad entre otras cosas
precisamente por menor acceso a la salud
o los tratamientos por ejemplo a este
inhalador que veíamos o no pero también
por estos disparadores ambientales el
tabaco la humedad en las casas no tener
peores condiciones de habitabilidad
provoca que haya más casos de asma o que
el asma se dispare con más frecuencia
Así que no hay mejor día que hoy para
recordar que es una enfermedad
totalmente tratable que con acceso a
estos tratamientos medicamentos y pues
reduciendo los factores ambientales se
puede vivir una vida con total
normalidad pero que sin la posibilidad
de hacer eso al final el asma termina
siendo una enfermedad que hace Mella en
las capas de la sociedad siempre más
desfavorecidas haciendo perder días de
trabajo haciendo perder días de escuela
o incluso teniendo impactos en la Salud
Mental Al fin y al cabo no con el miedo
de tener otro ataque de asno de sentir
que no se pueden realizar actividades
que sí están permitidas para el resto
del mundo pues información que es útil y
que nos hace un llamado a la prevención
gracias a usted Muchas gracias Ángela